you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
alex sharma tells sky news the cop 26
summit
will go ahead in glasgow in november
a new initiatives launch to bring
together the net zero aims of big
financial institutions around the world
we speak to mark
carney who's chairing it and
replanting england's carbon-absorbing
seagrass
meadows
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come now the president of cop
26 has told sky news the uk government
is still planning for the summit to take
place in glasgow in november
it'll be the biggest climate meeting
since the 2015 paris accord
where countries agreed to limit global
warming to 2 degrees
ideally 1.5 degrees above pre-industrial
levels
alex sharma said plans are still in
place for the conference to take place
in person
although there will also be some virtual
elements
he spoke to our climate correspondent
lisa holland
i do not sense uh any desire from the
part of countries to delay
cop any further and we are working very
hard and planning on a physical event
taking place in glasgow in november and
actually what is really important is for
all countries the smaller countries the
larger countries
to sit together on a level playing field
at the same table
that is what i'm being told when i'm
speaking to governments when i'm going
around the world
and that is what we are working very
hard to make sure happens you can't rule
out surely that it won't take place in
some other form that it be slimmed down
that large parts of it will be virtual
you surely have to be planning for that
well as i said what what we want to
ensure and we're working very hard on
this is a physical cop but you raise a
very important point
about the virtual aspects of this and
i've been very clear right from the
start
is that i want this to be the most
inclusive uh summit uh
ever and of course uh we have learned of
the last year that you can do things
virtually
and if we can expand effectively the the
people are able to
attend uh virtually then we will do that
and that is precisely what we're looking
at now
but of course it's also really important
for these negotiations
that they happen in a physical manner as
i said that's what we're working on
planning towards
the uk has set itself this ambitious
target which has been applauded around
the world
to reduce emissions by 78 by uh 2035.
you'll be aware of some criticism that
the policies are not in place to deliver
on that
ambition what would you say to that
firstly look at the record of what we've
done
as i said since the year 2000 we have
been the country
of all the g20 countries the the biggest
economies of the world
where we have decarbonized the fastest
um we have set out uh some of the
policies so
uh the prime minister's ten-point plan
uh for a green industrial revolution uh
which i worked on
uh as well we set that out last year we
sent out the energy white paper
as well which set out a sort of a range
of policies and what we will be setting
out
before cop 26 is our net zero strategy
as well so people will be able to see
you know how we're going to make the
progress well ahead of the cop 26
meeting
40 world leaders have been invited by
president biden
to take part in a virtual summit on
earth day tomorrow
and there have been some significant
announcements ahead of that
the uk government says it will reduce
emissions by 78
by 2035 compared with 1990 levels
and today eu member states have reached
an agreement to make the block
climate neutral by 2050. well with me is
our diplomatic editor dominic waghorn
so dominic commitments being made ahead
of earth day so what else can we expect
from this summit
well first and foremost this is about
america it's about america restoring its
credibility on climate change after
donald trump
trashed it by pulling america out of the
paris climate change agreement
so it's about america showing it can
lead the way forward and restore the
confidence of its allies on this crucial
issue
so to that end we're expecting an
announcement about an ambitious goal
that the americans say they will
announce tomorrow no further details
more than that but they say it's going
to be ambitious
also significant is the russians and
chinese are coming as well so if you add
them to the indians
and the europeans and the americans it
means that the big the world's big
carbon emitters
all on board in terms of china we're
probably not going to hear
announcements from the chinese at what
is an american organized event
but there is a sense of progress between
china and america
in the light of the shanghai meeting
between the the chinese climate envoy
and his american counterpart john kerry
over the weekend
there's a sense that they agree on the
same goals but not necessarily
how to reach them it is vital that they
all do make progress at this summit
ahead of the cop 26 in november
because at the moment things aren't
moving in the right direction in paris
all countries agreed to
reduce emissions instead emissions are
going up and global
temperature average temperature is
increasing too domino thank you
well we've got an earth day special
episode of our climate cast
podcast that's out on friday and you can
find it
wherever you normally get your podcast
from now let's take a look at some of
the day's other climate news now and
a coroner's urging the government to
change the law after
air pollution led to the death of a
nine-year-old girl
ella kissy deborah died of an asthma
attack in 2013 after she was exposed to
toxic
air philip barlow's report says
ministers should set
legally binding targets to reduce
pollution pollution
levels ella's mom rosamund kissy deborah
says the government isn't doing enough
it's now or never and you know we're
going to cop 26
we are world leaders we need to show the
the rest of the world
that we take this seriously so it's not
about 20 30 20 40
it's about now the general public needs
to know
the impacts that toxic air is having on
their
whole being australia plans to invest an
extra
417 million dollars on projects that
will reduce
greenhouse gas emissions the prime
minister scott morrison
says the money will be spent on building
hydrogen producing
hubs and carbon capture technology mr
morrison has been widely criticized for
not doing enough to tackle climate
change
biofuel made from chip fat might not be
as environmentally friendly as first
thought a new study by the transport and
environment campaign group
suggests there's no way of proving used
cooking oil that's imported into the uk
and europe is sustainable according to
researchers
more than half of the used cooking oil
that's made into fuel in europe
comes from abroad
[Applause]
scientists are using robots to monitor
the world's oceans
500 floating monitors have been deployed
by the global ocean
biogeochemistry project to track the
health of the sea
the robots will measure various things
including the acidity and
temperature of the ocean
and people in britain are going greener
than ever before
a study by the wwf and university of
york has found the uk's
overall carbon footprint has fallen by
17
research showed a 25 rise in people
adopting a plant-based
diet and the number of people using
renewable energy has almost doubled in
the last
18 months un special envoy on climate
action mark carney is chairing a new
initiative to bring together the net
zero aims of many of the world's biggest
banks asset managers asset owners and
insurers
the former bank of england governor will
lead the glasgow financial alliance for
net zero which
acts as an umbrella organization for the
various net zero coalitions
launched by the financial sector well
earlier i spoke to mark carney and
started by asking him
about that scheme we're taking this
alliance of banks
and for cop for glasgow we're bringing
them together with pension funds
so-called asset managers
um and all the other parts of the system
that are committed to net zero
in one glasgow alliance well yes so that
private investment very important but in
terms of
of government spending are you
comfortable with the idea of the
government spending
a huge amount given that we're coming
out of a coronavirus pandemic which is
still
raging worldwide do we have the money
there to spend the issue is not
just what you spend but how you spend it
um and as we emerge and i'm
obviously not the one to call exactly
the point where we properly emerged from
uh
from the coronavirus crisis although the
signs are more encouraging in the uk
as we emerge it becomes more and more
important that the
weight of government the support from
government for the economy
is focused on the future is investment
as opposed to current spending
so the type of spending in the economy
of the future which is more sustainable
which
better integrates a digital economy that
becomes critical and u.s president joe
biden is hosting
the earth day climate summit this week
what would you like to see come out of
that
the first thing we wanted to see come
out of that is exactly what's being
announced today
um that the core of the global financial
system is uh ready and
focused and there for this transition to
net zero the second thing
is the type of commitments that uh the
uk government is announcing
uh greater ambition from the largest uh
industrialized countries
uh is very important obviously uh at
that
in that last regard uh what the united
states does um and the knock-on impact
of that um so uh we'll see higher
climate ambition
uh but as as you know anna this is in
the context of a critical year
for the climate and for the global
economy
because after this summit the uk will be
hosting the g7
in cornwall in june follow on through to
a series of events in the run-up to
glasgow with culminating in glasgow
uh in november seagrass is a climate
superhero it can absorb huge quantities
of carbon
clean surrounding seawater and stabilize
the seabed well today england's largest
sea grass planting effort got underway
off the coast of plymouth
to try to support and improve the
resilience of our marine
environment our science correspondent
thomas moore went along to lend a hand
off the coast of plymouth they're
planting hope inside these hessian bags
are seeds of seagrass
dropped to the bottom by volunteers from
the ocean conservation trust
they should grow into a lush underwater
meadow
seagrass is a bit of a super plant it's
really important
provides us many ecosystem services so
it traps carbon
from the atmosphere does this really
efficiently can be up to 35 times more
efficient than rainforest in
capturing carbon in its sediment
seagrass shelters five times
more fish than bare seabed yet 92
percent of the meadows that once
surrounded the coast have been lost
if britain's seagrass meadows were
restored to how they once were
they'd store up to eleven and a half
million tons of carbon that's roughly
three percent
of our annual emissions nature could
help us
the planet is heading towards 1.5
degrees of warming
and the tipping points that could lead
to the melting of vast ice sheets and
the die back of the amazon
but new research shows as long as it's
quickly cooled the worst effects of
climate change could be avoided
if we were to cross a tipping point
threshold then the message is
don't give up there might still be this
opportunity
that we can get back and avoid the
catastrophic change
nature removes carbon from the
atmosphere far more cheaply and
efficiently than
any existing technology replanting
seagrass is a start
and it could have a crucial future
thomas more sky news in plymouth
tomorrow on the daily climate show we've
got a bumper earth day program we'll see
how people around the world are marking
the day
and bringing all the key developments
from the leaders meeting hosted by
president biden that's at the same time
tomorrow on sky news
see you then